a va bene l'importante è che sia pietro
9 scherzo ma forse appello a tutti i
ragazzi venuti questo video e sono
parigi oggi siamo su ultimate epic bat
simulator meno male che c'è scritto
perché non mi sarei mai ricordato il
nome allora vi spiego è una cosa
fighissima veramente troppo [ __ ] che
simula una battaglia in poche parole non
avreste mai detto
tra cose cioè tu puoi scegliere delle
cose per combattere e bellissimo puoi
fare tipo anche zombie contro gente a
caso non ho mai visto niente visto gioco
quindi spero di dio che sia una roba
decente ma io cosa cosa vedo
gli arcieri bene a minchia porca eva
leggetevi almeno distanti gesù qualcosa
mi dice che quelli sono gli haters e
questi siamo noi gli arcieri avevano la
mia stessa voglia di vivere in sta
partita ma gli hanno arati in tre
secondi va beh credo che chi l'ex siano
troppo forti quindi va beh allora
facciamo così un t rex contro 250
arcieri speriamo che qualcosa faccia poi
vicine dove metterlo perché ne sapevo io
stavolta dovrebbe essere un po più easy
in teoria speriamo forza arcieri che
prima ho sbagliato come si fa con la
videocamera che non ho capito stava
caricando va bene deve fare è morto è
morto per fantini ammazzati veramente
pochi va bene quindi un t rex è
battibile presente to use elettrico
io non ho fatto nessun veto qua va bene
sticazzi di t rex proviamo a fare un po
di roba diverse tipo medievale cosa ci
posso mettere una minchia così mettere
la gente con la spada tipo i cavalieri
ok aspetti facciamo un attimo cavalieri
contro 50 roba ma bellissimo ma facciamo
un cavaliere contro 100 gallini la
curiosità è è veramente troppa regala
cambiamo mondo mettiamo città dei
crusade alle tanto mi metto sempre fuori
ma game il gioco è crashato bene le 100
galline erano difficili a caricarmi
immagino che sia tipo l'apocalisse
poiché bella mappa sarebbe bello farli
combattere in città dopo ci proviamo
solo per vedere queste sono i 100
gallina cosa allora dopo che hai lodato
il sole ammazza tutti sti pòlli no non
credo sia in grado di far non lo so che
questa è per la scienza per la scienza
vai sì ma così facciamo note zio cioè
tirana un po di spa data in più la
brutta fine di un uomo
poverino è durato veramente nuovo corso
cristo guarda guarda lì di come sono
carichi guarda ora come non sono per
niente impauriti
porca vacca sembra mio zio va bene
ragazzi 321 l'iva è la madonna che io
non pensavo di arrivare a un certo punto
nella mia vita e invece ci siamo
arrivati
sono contento fiero di me stesso
fiero del percorso da youtuber che sto
facendo fiero del mio canale e di voi
iscritti che mi vedete portare contenuti
di qualità giorno dopo giorno è l'essere
umano come sappiamo tutti è la specie
inferiore bene et son durati più di
prima ma effettivamente le galline
legali ne sanno il fatto loro solo
perché sono discendenti dei dinosauri
ma a proposito di dinosauri avanti o
mini fatemi vedere quando sapete fare
fatemi vedere che sareste sopravvissuti
all'estinzione e si è sì vabbè allora
posto molto bene
molto bene caro molto bene ok niente da
fare
c'è la categoria aiuti posso metterla
youtubers ma perché gli orchi ciclopi
giganti voi siete scemi dei bordelli
allucinanti allora ciclopi giganti le
mettiamo 15 t rex ne mettiamo 35 e poi
mettiamo un sacco di umani allora raga
questa dovete vedere questa è bellissima
allora abbiamo 35 t rex 15 ciclopi
giganti 25 orchi giga uncontratto 50
spadaccini 150 cavalieri 50 soldati
dell'esercito americano 50 l'esercito
tedesco 50 spartani e 50 romani
let's go questo è veramente un genocidio
non solo dopo succedere carica tutto
quello che vuoi amico mio ci sarà un
board è no vi prego questa veramente
fighissimo no non ho idea però sarà la
vita porca vacca che brutte sono i
giganti eccoli eccolo mi sa che non so
perché sono proprio tanti gli umani e
quindi non so come va a finire secondo
me se come perdiamo quindi di aumentare
un po di umani spaccio un cambiamento
sorry vediamo così va un pelo meglio
auguri cosa vedo ma quali stanno
sparando
sì ma state sparate marcava cosa vedo
ma quelli lanciano le rocce a regà vado
che bordello chi sta vincendo vanno a
male possibile
mi sa che gli spartani sono un po morti
dovreste sparare un po meglio però
giocate un po di più a four nights ci
hanno arati marati ford madonna porca
vacca che genocidio nora che affermi ho
dato troppa fiducia al genere umano ho
sbagliato dovevo dare minchia 5.000
minimo non ho veramente fanno cagare
questi 1500 2500 no veramente non ne
usciamo più
mi sa che stavolta è un po più difficile
però non sono proprio sicuro della
madonna quanti spar tanti stavolta ci
abbiamo il pieno e un po più grosso ma
sono comunque titubante via come ho
fatto a non scoprire questo gioco che il
gioco della vita come vai vai vai vai
vai vai vai verso tutti spadaccini e
contate come madonna che bordello forza
uomini
fatemi vedere questa è dura ma posso
impossessare le persone a figo burqa
vacca che male allora noi fa miss pose
sarà uno spadaccino uno in mezzo a caso
ciao mi chiamo pino sono qui per caso e
picchio i t rex spetta che vengo vengo e
ti picchio è niente sono morto scherza
non imposte siamo niente che non sono
capace attenzione attenzione signori
potremmo avere i vincitori stavolta non
ci sono ancora gli hogs porca vacca
salutano sparati un sacco lega porca
vacca che figata o cioè fammi un
processore uno di questi
che brutto porca vacca mena mena che ma
le regala sembra signore degli anelli
più o meno mi sa che hanno perso i
cattivi qua li ha nominati fortissimo e
del rigo signori questo è stata molto
più combattuta ma hanno vinto gli umani
nuclearizzato io come ho fatto a
scoprire questo gioco adesso qualcuno
spiega ragazzi stavolta ho suonato anche
un sacco di orchi che se stanno amena
orca vacca che male questa non ho idea
di chi possa vincere il nuovo [ __ ]
vaccaro
non voglio impossessare nessuno voglio
tenermi lontano ma una domanda se io
lancio la bomba nucleare laggiù vogliono
quelli di qua no no era per chiedere
porca va cosa ho visto barca vacca che
onda d'urto
io i poteri di dio posso decidere se
agevolare qualcuno molto bene qua non
sto capendo chi sta vincendo che un
board e credo stiano vincendo i cattivi
e ne sono sicuro
voleva mettere un pò più di velocità
credo che vincano credo i cattivi però
di pochissimo nel caso cosa cavolo vi è
però non vale io ho ucciso tutti e non
allora aspetta ha ucciso un sacco di
esseri umani io con quella bomba di
questi qua dovrebbero essere morti
non ho capito chi ha vinto mea culpa che
ho fatto fuori della gente che non dovrà
scusate ho fatto usato i poteri di dio
contro quelli sbagliati dai facciamo
ditemi voi se va così e se i soldati
devono avere stamira veramente orrida
una brutta forma donna ma ha sparate
giusto porca vacca che mira brutta
in teoria coi soldati e molto giocata la
partita non ho idea di chi potrà vincere
i kill ex sono quasi morti tutti
non saprei su chi scommettere lega
stavolta è proprio difficile perché i
soldati sono forti c'è meno meno noi t
rex conto babar dal disastro
mi sa che vincono i cattivi anche
stavolta porca vacca i soldati e vabbè
gli orchi erano un pò tanti ci avete
provato e niente e il rimasuglio
dell'umanità e questo ci stavano per un
po per un attimo ci ho creduto
va bene ha cambiato cioè la peta la
pecca quanti sono dio mio
sono alcuni sono laggiù addirittura va
bene e poi c'è chuck norris
ok non ci arrivano neanche non ha eccoli
adesso rio no dovete andare e linz
tallinn chuck norris attento c'è anche
che arrivano i primi 8 8 e la madonna
però ma do va bene la casta meno a tutti
guardali cosa arredo cosa vedo
e fortissimo arriva gente continua a
morire
guarda è fortissimo ma dove lavorava
signori abbiamo un vincitore non avrei
mai detto però a quanto pare chuck
norris stava metà vita è già si muore
andandone vulcano
così per curiosità no no non muore
i ragazzi spero che questo che vi sia
piaciuto come al solito ragazzi sia
video è piaciuto questo momento mi piace
anche lei faceva da dove iniziare se non
sarà per siti scheletri e noi ci
vogliamo ha proseguito da ragazzi
[Musica]